народу, що ви думаєте за 1%. Я думаю що
ми час можемо винайти Вам заборонити
їм все, що ти зібрався і знаєте ми я
готовий тут буде для того, щоб
показати що у нас правдою Буває
розправ Мені буває там кажуть
біштрейдингу покривання ось таким
величезним і туди садять покривають свій
мільярди всі вени ви мені прийшли тут
воювала Я б на мій канал що ж ми про
це бути тоді ніж я Я розумію не
відбувається
я ось вам уже п'ята десятия доба
Покажіть мені у свято у цих сказав
там матеріали такі дядько інформацію
росіянам
банкрут все фальсифікація з вами поки
що я написав все так, а що ти сюди
прийшов сидиш написав
це знову пампер